Donald Trump had a normal one the other
day
uncontrollably posting absurd videos to
truth social
this seems to be the latest thing where
Trump is using truth social almost like
a video blog where anytime something
just happens he has to go and record a
video and post it I'm just going to show
you what was posted within just a few
hours to give you a sense of the way
that this is all working here's a video
corruption at the highest level it was
just revealed that the 51 intelligence
officials who claimed Hunter Biden's
laptop from hell was Russian
disinformation we're not only lying they
were coordinated by the Biden campaign
itself so obsessed with Hunter Biden
recording videos on a whim
to try to go after Hunter Biden
continuing to present no viable policy
package for his presidency it was
corruption at the highest level and it
was a hoax perpetrated by Biden
Secretary of State Anthony blinken and
partisan intelligence officials to cover
up the truth about the Biden crime
families grotesque influence peddling
and Corruption Okay so
everything he's saying here is false
it's a lie it's made up and again just
recording these videos on a loop moments
later with a video about the fake news
for all of those media fools who say
everything was on the up and up with the
2020 presidential election and then got
on to report about 51 intelligence
agents that wrote a letter spreading
disinformation about Hunter Biden's
famous laptop computer knowing it was
fake and treasonous just days before the
election
you have committed all right I'm not
going to play all of this for you I'm
just giving you a flavor it's
uncontrollable then another video about
who the hell even knows what it turns
out that Joe Biden and the Biden White
House knew everything about the
unconstitutional raid by the FBI and doj
on Mar-A-Lago no evidence that this is
true either fight there
unequivocal denial they denied it they
said we know nothing about it we know
absolutely nothing about it we would
never do such a thing
they lied all right so then there's
another again it's just he's doing like
a video blog
um then posting a piece of an interview
from Newsmax but they are very good at
two things disinformation and cheating
on elections that's what they do you saw
that this information with this new
revelation that this was incredible that
51 intelligence agents totally lied I
think it's treason they totally lied
just before the election right before
the vote they lied and they said that
the computer which had all crimes on it
was Russian disinformation the computer
had crimes on it so this is happening
almost 24 hours a day at this point in
time think about where we have gotten in
2023 on the cusp of a major presidential
election a very uh content very much
contested Republican primary you have
Joe Biden
doing things and announcing a
re-election campaign that admittedly
many Americans don't want but he is
functioning as a president
accomplishing things and Donald Trump
sits at his house recording 30 to 50
second video blogs about conspiracy
theories he either misunderstood
or just as blatantly lying about
that's the contrast that we have my real
hope and I say this as a non-biden
cheerleader if this race comes down to
Biden versus Trump a rematch of 2020
which would be an incredible uh
situation in American history
I hope Trump genuinely gets crushed and
then we can say goodbye to Trump's
political career once and for all that
would really be a delightful outcome if
that that's where this ends up if it
ends up being Marianne Williamson versus
Ron DeSantis okay well then that'll be a
different situation but if it's Biden
Trump if that's the if the rematch
narrative is the one that ends up being
the reality
I want Trump to really get crushed and
to say sayonara to his political career
let's take a quick break we'll be back
with much more right after this
if you're looking for the perfect
Mother's Day gift our sponsor Aura
frames creates incredible Ultra quality
digital frames we're displaying pictures
and videos you can pre-load the frame
with your favorite memories pictures
videos for Mom to see when she opens it
up you can update it with unlimited
photos and videos from anywhere using
the aura frames app no fees ever no
limits on storage Aura frames was voted
the number one digital picture frame by
wire cutter the strategist and Wired
Magazine my mom loves the frame I gave
her I also have an aura frame in my
house when we were just traveling I was
able to immediately add pictures which
pop up on my mom's frame and I've
noticed the photos look like real prints
such high resolution and the display is
calibrated so that you can not even tell
it's a screen Aura frames has an awesome
Mother's Day deal for my audience you'll
get up to thirty dollars off their
best-selling Carver map frame and free
shipping go to auraframes.com Pacman use
the code Pacman the link is in the
description